-It is Kate McKinnon!
That's exactly what you want.
I am so happy you
have entered the building.
-Okay, that was fun.
Thank you so much.
-No, no, no, no. We have more.
I didn't even
start a question yet.
Kate, I have a lot to
talk to you about,
because I got to see you
quickly in London.
-Yes.
-We saw each other fast.
-I was there.
-Yeah, you were in London.
-I saw you and I left,
because why I would stay?
-Yeah. What else does London
have to offer?
-It's Fallon, baby. That's it.
-But you brought a --
You brought a photo.
And I got to be honest,
I knew what this was.
-Oh, you did. So, I didn't.
So, I like to walk.
I like to see stuff.
And I saw -- Thank you.
-Yeah.
-Thank you.
-Amazing. We do, too.
-It's important to get out there
and see what is up.
So, I love bugs.
And I saw this baby
on the street.
And I was like, "Oh, my God."
This moth. What?
It's, like, sepia-toned wing,
fishnets, basically.
-Basically. It's gorgeous.
-Peek of red with polka dots.
Like, this is
a burlesque dancer.
-Yeah, this is the most gorgeous
bug I've ever seen.
-This moth has
tassels on her boobs
and is ready to do a wig change.
-Yes.
-This is, like, a moth.
-And then I saw,
a few days later --
-This in "The New York Times."
-You're supposed to --
-"Kill this bug."
Kill. They want you to kill
this -- murder this bug.
-Kill with no mercy, they said.
Kill it with no mercy.
-Spotted lantern fly.
-Yeah, so, apparently, they're
an incredibly invasive pest,
and you're supposed to
murder them on contact.
And I was, like,
"Um, yeah, okay, I will."
-You were not.
-Because --
-You were like,
"Where did I find that moth?"
And you had to go back
to that location to --
-The next one I see,
I'm going to be like, "Run!
Run!"
-You are not.
-No, we're supposed to.
No, we're supposed to.
We're supposed to, and I will.
I will kill
the next lantern fly I see.
-But take a photo of it.
Oh, my God. You're winking.
-No, we're supposed to.
I will.
I will kill the next one.
-Can I tell you what's
interesting right now?
-Uh-huh. Yeah, yeah.
-I saw, last year on
"Saturday Night Live,"
Chloe Fineman did
an impression of you to you.
-Yeah.
-An impression of you to you.
-She did. It was great.
-She kind of nailed it.
This is a picture of --
-I don't know what she's --
I don't sit like that.
-I mean, you kind of --
-I don't -- I would never sit --
-You kind of sit like that.
-How weird would that be
if I just, like,
sat like that all the time?
-You do kind of
sit like that, though.
-Yeah, I do.
-You announced earlier this year
that you're leaving
"Saturday Night Live."
-I did. You know, I left.
I left "Saturday Night Live."
-You left it, bud.
But what a great run.
-The love of my life.
-We're going to miss you.
-"Saturday Night Live."
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thanks.
-We're going to miss you.
You were so great.
-I'm going to miss it.
-Did you clear out the office
and all that stuff?
-I have not yet
cleared out my office,
because there's just too much --
There's like a decade
of junk in there.
I think I'm going to leave
behind some surprises.
-Yeah.
Which is nice of you to do.
-Because I started collecting --
You know, I had to play
Anthony Fauci a lot
and some other people that
required the use of prosthetics.
So I started, just for fun,
collecting the prosthetic items,
the noses and ears
and things like that.
And I started making little art
pieces with them in my office.
Like, I said to
a writer friend like,
"Oh, come get your Gatorade.
It's in my office."
And then I sort of had done --
had made that.
-Piece of art.
-Just a bouquet of
noses and ears.
-Yeah.
-And then I said
to one of the writers,
"Just go --
I left something on the piano.
Can you go find it?"
-I mean, that's all Fauci noses.
-And those are noses.
-They're noses, by the way.
-They're noses.
-Just for -- Yeah.
Just for NBC censors.
Yeah, that's what they are.
They're noses.
But are you prepared for
a non-"SNL,"
a year of not going into work
at 1:00 in the afternoon
and staying up until
4:00 in the morning every night?
-I'd like to --
I'd like to think I am.
My cat has been like,
"Oh, now you're home.
After a decade of you
being gone, out all hours,
now you're home.
Fine.
Well, I'm already asleep."
-"Well, I'm not --
Well, then fine.
Then I'm going to sleep."
-"Well, now I'm staying up.
I'll stay up all night,
and you won't know where I am.
How about that?"
-Was it fun for you to
do "DC League of Super-Pets?"
-Oh, it was wonderful.
It was wonderful.
-You were fantastically funny
in that.
And I thought the idea
is actually brilliant,
that superheroes
should have pets.
-It's -- And the pets are
heroes, as well.
-Yes! Wow! Remember that.
-The more you know.
-The more you know, yeah.
-Yeah.
-This is who you play.
Is that the cutest thing
you've ever seen?
-Yeah, so, that's Lulu.
She's the evil guinea pig.
-Star of the movie. Oh, my gosh.
You were the villain
of the movie.
-Yes, yes. But it's still --
-The cutest thing
you've ever seen and so funny.
-How bad could that be?
-But you are actually
a guinea pig who Lex Luthor
has tested chemicals and stuff
and superpowers on Lulu.
-Yes, and now she's got
an ax to grind.
-That's exactly right. Yeah.
So, finally,
the guinea pig is getting back
and saying,
"Yeah, don't test stuff on me."
-But this is -- To me, this is
the essence of
a comedic character,
an evil guinea pig.
-You got giant laughs from
7-year-olds to 47-year-old.
-Well, that makes me so happy.
Thanks.
-You got -- I wish --
-That makes me happy.
-I wish --
If I had your number, I --
I just wanted to, like, play it,
because you were crushing it.
-Oh, that's really nice.
-Yeah.
And you weren't even there,
but it was --
You crushed it, and you have to
feel good about this.
You made a lot of people happy.
-Thanks.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Kate McKinnon in
"DC League of Super-Pets."
Take a look at this.
-The dog is right.
He should seek his freedom.
-You see that? Lulu gets it.
-And he must destroy all
who stand in his way.
[ Cage creaking ]
-Wow. That just took a turn.
-You may kid yourself
with your silly fun,
but I have the device!
For one day soon,
when the stars align,
the device will bring me
ultimate power and I will be...
-You'll be more than free.
-...more than free.
Exactly.
-Lulu, whatever they
tested on you in that lab
left you a few guineas
short of a pig.
That device is just
a pile of garbage.
-You fear my brilliance.
[ Chuckles ]
Recede into shadows.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Kate McKinnon, everybody!
"DC League of Super-Pets"
is in theaters now.
We'll be right back with
Lili Reinhart.
Stick around, everybody.